Je suis de bonne humeur aujourd'hui j'fait mon entrée en marchant en arrière, j'suis un gangster
Bon.
Je vous ai demandé sur twitter ce que vous voudriez être
ou qui vous,
comment vous voudriez être
à fin
de réaliser votre rêve!
à savoir vous transformer comme ça,
Par exemple si vous rêvez d'être Brad Pitt
Je peux vous faire devenir
Brad Pitt bien-sûr.
Bien-sûr à l'aide d'un logiciel qui s'appelle...
Vegas Pro.
ET PAS PHOTOSHOP
*rire chelou*
Tout le monde dans le youtubegames se moque de moi parce que...
Je suis le dernier mec en vie à utiliser Vegas Pro pour faire ses montages
100% des gens sont passer sur Adobe Première Pro et moi je.. je reste dans le passé j'arrive pas à évoluer
Bon
Trève de plaisanterie
Alors
Elle voudrait être une mongolfière
Bon, c'est facile
on va commencer par trouver une image merveilleuse de mongolfière
Hein
Attends mais je sais pas si la tête sera assez grosse
Si c'est bon, c'est bon
*Rires*
*Musique*
Très bien, je viens de passer 9 minutes à essayer de rendre quelqu'un en montgolfière
*Rires*
Ah c'est dégueulasse
ça me plait énormément
Je me chauffe là, j’avoue c'est pas ouf, mais je me chauffe
Well
J'aimerai que l'on gagne en street cred
Hey les mecs c'est chaud là
Attends je sais ce qu'on va faire, on va taper gangsta sur shutterstok
Bah voilà, pas besoin de faire de photo montage, on dirait PV Nova
C'est niquel, c'est bon
Il va pas me casser les couilles
Aller ça c'est fait
J'ai toujours rêver de pouvoir me déplacer à l'aide d'un Hand Spinner custom de ouf !
Oh non ! Mais Germain, cette position ça va pas du tout!
Faut pas faire ça
Bon je vais réaliser ton rêve
Alors, on va commencer par t'isoler
*Bruits souris*
Je suis le seul mec au monde à détourer à la main
Tu sais sur Photoshop tu as l'outil détoure tout seul, voilà BIM c'est magique.
Moi je suis là avec ma put*in de main, comme une énorme mer*e, c'est scandaleux
Alors, maintenant que Germain est isolé et que l'on peut faire ce que l'on veut de lui
De ce petit Germain
Et tu sais quoi, je vais te faire déplacer sur ton propre Hand Spinner mon pote
Ah bah voilà, on est perfectionniste ou on l'est pas après
Hop, Je crois, je suis pas sur, que je viens peut-être de réaliser ton rêve
Et voilà, Germain qui s'envole, sur son Hand Spinner, c'est beau
Ce soir en ouvrant ta fenêtre à 2h du mat' car il commence à faire hyper chaud
Tu verras peut-être Nozman passé comme ça, dans le ciel
On sait pas
Maxenss qui nous dis : J'aimerai bien ressembler à Mickael Jackson. Et être sur scène, Merci !
Putin mais mec là, on part de loin
Bon déjà de base, il faut juste isolé son visage
Petit visage là, petit visage mais pas petit nez !
OOOHHH!
*Rires*
Il va me défoncer pour avoir dit ça put*in
Ok, non non non, ne croyez pas que c'est une blague et que je détoure un zizi, c'est fait exprès
Vous allez voir
Pour le moment ça ressemble à ça, mais vous allez voir après, ça va être exceptionnel
Haha! Oh oui, celle là elle est bien ! Celle là elle est parfaite
Et Messieurs Dames, merci d’accueillir Maxenss
Jackson sur scène
*Beat It de Michael Jackson*
Incroyable, exceptionnel, ton rêve est devenu réalité Maxenss
merci.
C'est la magie, c'est la magie !
Bon quoi d'autre, quoi d'autre, c'était un peu facile hein!
J'ai toujours rêvé d'être un Donuts, au chocolat!
Attends, tous les Youtubeurs ils en profitent quoi, ils se lâchent!
On a YouTunes, on a notre Donuts, il y a plus qu'a mixer les deux!
Ah ça me donner fin de détrourer ça mon gars, j'ai archi faim!
Il est 13h28, j'ai toujours pas manger, ça me rend dingue!
En faîte c'était prévu depuis le début, il savait que j'avais pas manger, il voulait juste me mettre une énorme dalle
Bien joué mon pote, mais tu feras moins le malin quand tu auras une gueule de Donuts !
Bon mec j'avoue tu n'es pas devenu un Donuts
mais tu avais un torticolis, tu as pris ce que tu avais sous la main
pour le soigner, voilà
désolé YouTunes
C'est mon copain et moi, tu peux faire en sorte que ça soit Capitaine America à sa place stp merci
En vrai il a déjà tout de Captain America ton copain
Je dirai même que c'est Captain America mais quand il est pas habillé en super héros
Du coup pour que tu le trouve plus séduisant, j'ai juste à rajouter le masque de Captain America
Et voilà, c'est comme un superman, on le reconnait plus dès qu'il a son masque
Ok tu es pas contente j'ai compris, si tu veux je peux éventuellement te rajouter les yeux de Captain America
Voilà, tu trouves vraiment que ça le rend plus beau ?
Tu trouves vraiment que ça le rend plus beau d'avoir  un œil de travers ?
Alors aime ton copain comme il est, et arrete de fantasmer sur ce putin de Capitaine America
En plus Iron Man il est plus fort
Quoi d'autre, quoi d'autres les filous
J'aimerai être chauve stp
Bah il y a des tas de gens qui sont chauves et qui aimeraient l'inverse
Mais bon si tu veux
Tu veux donc un crane chauve, pas de soucis, je te trouve ça pépère
Les chauves il y en a partout mec, y compris sur google
On va te mettre le crane chauve d'un mec qui fait des shooting photo pour un site de farces et attrapes
ça n'a aucun sens ce que je suis en train de faire
Bon j'ai un peu de mal avec ce crane, il me pose des difficultés
Non mais voilà, je préfère vous le dire, mais ça va le faire
*Musique*
Bon voici à quoi tu ressemblerais avec un crane chauve et des morceaux de décor derrière toi qui disparaisse
on sait pas pourquoi, c'est pas ma faute, je sais pas pourquoi
peut être qu'il y avait des cheveux à la place avant
et je savais pas trop comment le corriger donc j'ai fait de la mer*e
on sait pas
On va faire un compromis mec, tu peux pas dire je veux être chauve, comme ça
ça marche ma comme ça, il faut équilibrer
si on retire quelque chose, on le met ailleurs
du coup petite solution que je te propose, tes cheveux iront ici
tout simplement
on ne peut pas comme ça retirer ces cheveux, ils doivent aller quelque part
c'est impossible sinon
Bon, suivant
Donne moi les Totally Spies
Et oui !! Avec marfly, MARFLY hahaha
Mec j'ai faim putain
Ici une vrai question se pose, qui est quelle fille ?
Moi je vais être Sam, parce que Sam c'est un peu la sagesse
C'est un peu ce que je ne suis pas finalement
En vrai la vrai raison c'est que j'étais amoureux d'elle quand j'étais petit
J'étais fan, complètement fan, j'avais envoyer des lettres et tout à TF1
Pour dire, dites à Sam que je l'aime
Je suis Sam, ça c'est fait
Super
Oh Carlito, je pense que lui c'est Jerry en faîte, c'est pas du tout...
Mec, c'est trop Carlito en plus vieux mec !
Très clairement, et en bien blanc parce qu'il est proche de la mort
Oh, attention Jerry en approche
Carlito-Jerry bien-sur qui fait cette tête parce qu'il se rend compte à ce moment précis
qu'il n'a pas de pectoraux
Et voilà, les totally spies
On est pas mal, totarlito
Excellent !
Oh Mcfly ! Rend nous plus jeune que toi !!
Ok, ok les gars, ok ok ok
je sais que votre age vous complexe beaucoup
on va tout de suite régler ce problème ensemble, aujourd'hui !
Macfly, j'ai retrouver une photo de toi quand tu étais bébé
à l'instant sur google, j'ai tapé macfly bébé je suis tombé sur
cette image
voilà
carrément ressemblant
alors après un dur travail
Macfly c'est fait, c'est bon *Rires*
Macfly est devenu plus jeune que moi, il manque plus que Carlito
attention, et BIM, je crois que là les mecs, je ne pouvais pas faire mieux
j’espère que vous allez mieux vivre votre crise de la trentaine grâce à cette photo
En tout cas moi je me sens déjà vieux en la voyant
Celle-là il faut que je l'imprime et que je la foute là
comme ça dès que je me sentirai mal je la regarderai ça ira mieux
Je veux des corps d'athlètes !
Ohlalalala, c'est terrible, ils sont irrattrapables c'est deux garçons !
Je pense que ça va être beaucoup plus simple qu'il n'y parait vous allez voir
Celle là je ne vais mettre que 15 minute à la faire au lieu de 36!
*Musique*
Bon je viens de travailler sur cette photo
Vous pensiez que c'était infaisable, mais les amis regardez
on va passer d'un corps qui subit un peu la vie
à des belles tablettes de chocolats !
et ouais ce montage est bien fait !
C'est le premier que j'arrive à bien faire, qu'est-ce qui ce passe mon gars !
Par contre pour ce qui est de son camarade
Franchement il est assez musclé comme ça !
Je trouve qu'il y a pas grand chose à modifier quoi
alors, on passe à autre chose !
Je veux que Maurice, mon chat me prenne dans ses bras, stp
Mon gars, j'aimerai bien aussi que mes chats me prenne dans leurs bras des fois
qu'ils me caressent, qu'ils me nourrissent, etc...
Je vais te mettre bien mec, je vais réaliser ce rêve !
Les amis, j'ai passé 20 minutes sur cette photo
Pour un résultat moyennement satisfaisant !
*Clap Clap*
Ouais, c'est pas fou, bon...
Et voilà les amis, c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo
n’hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plus
Je sais pas si elle sera courte ou pas, mais je pense que oui
parce que je me doutais pas que ça allait me prendre autant de temps de photoshoper des images mec !
Et je ferai plus jamais ça !
Je m’aperçois en faîte que j'ai carrément un skill de mer*e !
Je suis plus fort en géographie qu'en montage photo !
Vous vous rendez compte ou pas ?
Pourtant sur mes miniatures je m'en sors bien
Regardez, là je m'en suis bien sorti, là je m'en suis bien sorti
enfin je m'en sors quoi sur mes miniatures, vite fait
Un peu !!
Aller, on a quand même fait 6 ou 7 heureux aujourd'hui avec ces montages merveilleux
on a exaucé des rêves, et pour ça, on peut être fière de nous !
Je veux dire, devenir une montgolfière c'est quand même une chance !
Et tout le monde n'a pas cette chance
À bientôt
*Musique douce*
*Musique E.T. l'extraterrestre*
*Musique générique*